[Musique]
allez vous regarder je suis comme vous
mais dans la même merde j'ai une chaîne
aussi je suis désolé j'ai appris que
j'avais été pris en otage par des
musulmans j'ai 20 ans c'est quoi vous
voulez dire terroristes non ouais parce
que j'en ai vrai nom justement vous avez
dit ok ce qu'ils veulent là on est plus
pasqua est bas
je sais pas trop je me rêvais aussi mais
en regardant autour ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on a à faire un psychopathe ou pire
un fanatique de l'islam
en fait ce que j'essaie de dire c'est
que rester ici peut faire de nous des
hommes morts ou encore pire des hommes
converties à l'islam
je pense que c'est la situation qui vous
perturbe pas mal et c'est ce que
j'essaie de dire c'est qu'on ait deux
justement on peut s'entraider pour
trouver une solution il ya sûrement un
moyen de sortir d'ici n'en pensais pas
je vous laisse chercher vous a l'air de
savoir
[Musique]
on comprend soudain les est renouvelée
pour l'effrayer jeu c'est le privilège
d'avoir été choisi de participer à ces
tests psychologiques
en volley n'est ce pas eh bien les gérer
ça posséder chacun une arme afin que
nous traversons approchant les 2 armées
contre une seule pas que des succès
impressionnants
c'est la fin de ce contrat dont il n'y a
pas là en train de vous qu'il mord à gaz
mortel loi et non de la caisse laquelle
devra survivre à ce petit jeu et bien je
voulais champêtre à l'ecla ça c'est un
connard ça se voit que ce n'est même pas
un mec bien grossi sera comme ça de sa
race
vous allez trouver un truc là une issue
non jeu plus de riz qu'ils en ont l'air
finalement d'ailleurs par brassage pour
poser une question
allez-y est ce que vous considérez comme
comme raciste je suis juste lucide
ouvrir les yeux un peu du coup vous
comptez pas changé d'avis par hassan
non ce serait se montrait faibles
d'esprit ouailles et puis moi ils me
font pas peur qu'on puisse assumer
pleinement tout ce que vous pensez de a
à z à 100%
oui oui absolument
il ya en même temps j'ai un peu envie de
vous dire que c'est peut-être lié à
l'éducation que m'a donné mon père parce
que quand j'étais petit c'était très
comme ça quand la maison et puis c'était
compliqué de penser par soi même donc
quatre minarets c'est moi parce à
détester les musulmans et c'est comme ça
c'est ça c'est un c'est un état s'est
établie chez non je les déteste pas je
dis non je les comprends pas en fait les
détester enfin au fond vous laisse vous
les détestez mais non je vous dis que
messi vous les détestez chez tandis que
non [ __ ] mais vous avez touché un
point intéressant
effectivement quand j'étais petit mon
père l'avait emmené une fouille tom tu
vas avoir un site de merde je le savais
vous étiez l'un d'eux est sain depuis le
début je me disais en fait puis moi je
vous fais confiance parce que justin pas
ok mais vous savez que trahir vous savez
que répandent le mal autour de vous et
pas à les attirer moi j'ai points puis
dans un [ __ ] monde vous existez de
façon à leur siège d'air guitar hier
elle est folle regarde dans les yeux et
se dire
vas-y
aucune
le matin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]